يوصي الأطباء بأن تجلس العائلات
وتتحدث عن أهدافها الصحية
للعام الجديد والتي يجب أن تشمل
أطفالهم ، حتى الأطفال الصغار يجب أن
يفكروا في الاعتناء بأنفسهم ،
فيما يلي بعض اقتراحات قرارات العام الجديد
للمجموعة الأصغر سنًا من
الأكاديمية الأمريكية لطب الأطفال  اغسل
يديك بعد الذهاب إلى الحمام
وقبل تناول فرشاة أسنانك بالفرشاة مرتين في
اليوم ولا تضايق الحيوانات التي قد
تبدو ودودة ولكن يمكنها أن تعض إذا
شعرت بالتهديد وشرب الماء قليل الدسم أو
الحليب الخالي من الدسم كل يوم
يجب أن تكون المشروبات السكرية  تعامل مع الخروج والتحرك ابحث
عن رياضة أو نشاط تحبه وافعل ذلك
قدر الإمكان ارتدي خوذة عند
ركوب الدراجة وحزام الأمان عند
الركوب في السيارة والأهم من ذلك
أن تكون لطيفًا مع الآخرين ، فلا أحد يحب المتنمر
بكل الطرق الرائعة  تربية أطفال سعداء بصحة جيدة في
هذا العام الجديد للدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا آندي روز